thanks radio for telling us about the
importance of proper dessert selection
so let's choose our desserts now the
earliest platform version that our Apple
support is gingerbread at the current
time choosing Gingerbread means we can
cover over 99% of the devices active on
google playstore it's also the cutoff
for using Google Play services for
things like maps and location and the
Android support library the support
library package offers an implementation
of UI features that were added in later
releases of Android but now can be used
on older versions of the platform so
it's really useful
notice that we pick the latest version
of Gingerbread with API level 10 because
it contains additional bug fixes that
API level 9 doesn't have then we can go
ahead and click Next we're going to
choose the template blank activity with
fragment for background context and
activity serves as the presentation
layer for our UI and the fragment
represents a behavior or portion of the
screen and now we have an option to
modify the names of the files that will
be auto-generated from the wizard the
name of our activity is main activity
and the layout will come from activity
underscore main which is an XML file in
a similar fashion the fragments layout
will come from fragment underscore main
which is also an XML file I'm going to
do a small change for the name of the
menu file to be called main XML because
on an older version of Android studio
that was the default name then we go
ahead and hit finish and now you should
have a newly created sunshine app with
the files on the left here by default
you may see the Android view of the
files which is a flattened version of
the project structure and it highlights
the key Android source files that you'll
need to edit in this course though we're
going to be using the project view
because that's what we had on the older
version of Android studio you can choose
any view that you prefer though make
sure you wait for the Gradle build to
finish if you have any errors you can
check the guide in the instructor notes
below as a tip you can check the build
up Gradle file which is located under
the app folder you want to make sure
that the compiled SDK version and the
target SDK version are both pointing at
the latest stable version of the
platform in this case it's 21 for the
Android 5.0 lollipop release once it's
done building we can add a custom app
icon that's more fitting for our weather
app right-click on the app folder and
click new image asset you can choose
from any of the clip art options or you
can use the one that we
provide in the download below then use a
placeholder icon we provide in a
download below now this will show up in
the all apps screen so that clicking on
this app icon will launch our app it
will also show up in the overview space
if sunshine is one of your most recent
tasks the other lace you might see this
app icon is in the action bar of our app
in certain videos of this course that
were filmed earlier on KitKat by default
the action bar shows the app icon with
material design on lollipop and later
the app icon doesn't show up by default
anymore so don't worry if you don't see
it it's fine and we're going to be
styling the action bar later in less
than 5 anyways